THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Jesse: ALSO HERE TONIGHT
LOUISIANA SENATOR JOHN KENNEDY.
I MEAN, SENATOR KENNEDY, FIRST
THEY DON'T WANT YOU TO GO PRISON
AND THEN WHEN YOU DO GO TO
PRISON FOR A HEINOUS CRIME, THEY
WANT TO MAKE IT AS CUSHY AND AS
FAVORABLE AS POSSIBLE.
WHY DO YOU THINK THEY WANT TO DO
THAT?
>> BECAUSE THEY ARE WOKE.
WITH RESPECT TO CRIME.
I WOULD RATHER BE FORCED TO
LISTEN TO O.J. JOKES FOR THE
REST OF ETERNITY THAN TO TAKE
THE ADVICE OF PRESIDENT BIDEN OR
GOVERNOR NEWSOM.
THEY ARE BOTH NAUSEOUSLY WOKE.
AND ONE OF THE CARDINAL TENETS
OF WOKEISM IS THAT THE CRIMINAL
IS THE VICTIM.
THE VICTIM ISN'T THE VICTIM.
THE CRIMINAL IS THE VICTIM.
WOKERS BELIEVE THAT NO ONE
SHOULD HAVE TO ACCEPT
RESPONSIBILITY.
THEY BELIEVE THAT IT'S ALWAYS
SOMEONE ELSE'S FAULTED.
AND THEIR MOTTO IS HEAR NO EVIL,
SEE NO EVIL, PROSECUTE NO EVIL.
NOW, FORTUNATELY, MOST
AMERICANS, AT LEAST THOSE WHO
HAVE THE IQ OF ABOVE A SLOTH
UNDERSTAND THAT'S NOT THE WAY
THE REAL WORLD WORKS.
MOST AMERICANS UNDERSTAND THAT
UNFORTUNATELY, AND FOR WHATEVER
REASON, THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE IN
OUR SOCIETY, JESSE, WHO ARE NOT
SICK, THEY ARE NOT CONFUSED.
THEY ARE NOT MIXED UP.
IT'S NOT THAT THEIR MOMMA OR
DADDY DIDN'T LOVE THEM ENOUGH.
THEY ARE JUST BAD.
OR AT LEAST THEY DO VERY BAD
THINGS.
AND THAT'S WHY WE HAVE TO HAVE
PRISONS.
AND WITH RESPECT TO THOSE PEOPLE
WHO SAY OH MY GOSH, I'M IN
PRISON, ISN'T THIS TERRIBLE, I
WOULD SAY, LOOK, IF YOU DON'T
WANT TO GO TO PRISON, DON'T DO
ILLEGAL STUFF.
BUT THE COROLLARY TO THAT IS,
WHAT YOU ALLOW IS WHAT WILL
CONTINUE.
>> Jesse: YOU ARE RIGHT.
>> AND IF YOU DO DO REALLY BAD
STUFF, WE HAVE TO SEND FOLKS
LIKE THAT ANTI-SOCIETY TO
PRISON.
OTHERWISE, YOU ARE JUST GOING TO
GET MORE OF THE SAME.
AND, UNFORTUNATELY, I HATE THAT
I'M SORRY TO HAVE TO SAY IT, BUT
BOTH PRESIDENT BIDEN AND
GOVERNOR NEWSOM HAVE ADOPTED
THIS JAUNDICED VIEW OF REALITY.
>> Jesse: WHEN YOU ARE AT THE
SENATE CAFETERIA AND YOU GUYS
ARE DRINKING THE LITTLE MILKS,
YOU KNOW, OR YOU PEAL IT OPEN
LIKE THAT OR MAY BE SITTING
AROUND THE TABLE GOSSIPPING FROM
SOME COLLEAGUES FROM THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE AISLE, DO YOU SENSE
THAT SOME OF YOUR DEMOCRATIC
COLLEAGUES ARE GETTING THE ANGER
THAT IS ERUPTING ACROSS THE
COUNTRY ABOUT THIS
OUT-OF-CONTROL CRIME OR IS IT
JUST KIND OF GOING IN ONE EAR
AND OUT THE OTHER?
WILL.
>> NO, I THINK THEY GET IT.
>> Jesse: THEY DO?
WHY AREN'T THEY DOING ANYTHING
ABOUT IT OR SAYING ANYTHING?
>> THERE HAVE A VARIETY OF
REASONS.
SOME OF MY DEMOCRATIC
COLLEAGUES.
OF COURSE SOME OF MY DEMOCRATIC
COLLEAGUES, AS IS THEIR RIGHT.
SOME OF THEM ARE WOKE.
OTHERS ARE SCARED OF THE WOKERS.
OTHERS DON'T WANT TO CROSS
PRESIDENT BIDEN.
THEY STARTED -- WELL, THEY
DIDN'T, SOME OF THE WOKERS
STARTED THE DEFUND AND
DISRESPECT THE POLICE MOVEMENT.
THEY TOLERATED IT PRESIDENT
BIDEN ALLOWED IT TO HAPPEN.
AND YOU SEE THE RESULT.
IT'S SAFER TO WALK DOWN THE
STREETS OF MOGADISHU THAN IT IS
TO WALK DOWN THE STREETS OF NEW
YORK.
AND I HAVE SAID THIS BEFORE.
CHICAGO AND TO SOME EXTENT MY
CITY IN LOUISIANA, NEW ORLEANS,
THAT I LOVE TO DEATH.
THEY HAVE BECOME THE WORLD'S
LARGEST OUTDOOR SHOOTING RANGES.
WHAT YOU ALLOW IS WHAT WILL
CONTINUE.
AND AS LONG AS WE ALLOW THIS,
THE CRIMINALS ARE NOT GOING TO
BE UNHAPPY WITH THIS.
AND THEY ARE GOING TO KEEP
COMMITTING CRIMES.
>> Jesse: IT'S COMMON SENSE BUT
YOU ARE EXACTLY RIGHT.